[Music]
in flight delay news submitted by
choo-choo [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] two women
were removed from a flight after ranting
about the Muslim passengers on board
race 1 maybe they should have removed
the Muslims and gave them first-class ha
you see how I turned that around so this
took place in Turkey which is a country
like what the [ __ ]
exactly so that's like go to China air
and be like these stupid-ass Ching
chongs what the [ __ ]
so this occurred on a Thomas Cook
Airlines flight that was from Turkey to
England to Gatwick and so there were
these two women that were kicked off the
flight after complaining that there were
three male Muslim passengers don't all
the passengers well know their complain
about these three out there specific
guys probably a lot of English people
that visited and Bolin I'm guessing I
don't even know nothing no cuz this
dongle is like a hub for a lot of
connecting flights
I could see like she didn't even visit
that place or whatever but if knows what
she's been there like five times I've
actually been there four times yes oke
flex all the time I didn't say anything
cuz I'm you're gonna do it anyways I
want to keep the glow away from you you
just gave me word glory thank you thank
you you never been to hamburger or
Hamburg I will be going that place
exists babe I will be going there though
anyway so there's this video that went
viral of this have you been to Boulder
Colorado no well I have good for you
you're supposed to jump in on that I
missed it have you been to Boulder okay
right here have you been at Boulder
Colorado I'm so jealous guys
okay very good Tulsa Oklahoma huh
oh he's pinkies Muslim yeah because I
got my races all [ __ ] up one of the
Muslim guys he got offended obviously
yeah because she's being [ __ ] racist
that lady looks like she is one of the
New Age liberal type of people that
enjoy the yoga the Lee suspected racist
but our undercover yeah their uncle okay
the term is a well-intentioned liberal
well inch oh yeah I like those they're
funny mm-hmm let me speak for minorities
type of liberal I think they're not
racist or they say that but then a lot
of their actions that's where the
barbecue Betty or Becky came from
whereas I did she has I think a PhD from
Stanford or somewhere else she's
socially stupid so yeah there's there's
a negative association where they'll
often associate some of these people
with being dumb but it's nice in all
classes all systems that occurs but she
on the surface would seem like oh she's
like an ally or this adadz like she's
the one that's making the call we don't
check our own personal biases so what
was that guy trying to just attack her
back verbally verbally I guess so this
all came to light because the passengers
are tweeting out what was happening and
so they're saying that this was a 1:25
a.m. flight from Turkey oh I was
delirious exactly delirious and then
those halls were drunk no so so what
happened was that they were before
boarding they were complaining actually
when they boarded they began complaining
and saying like oh you know like she's
having a panic attack because she sees
these Muslim men in the plane well maybe
the Muslim guys shouldn't have talked
about bombs and stuff I mean like the
drinks on the plane were bomb yeah
they're like hey bro this is bomb yeah
so then
they're saying that these two women
began to act distressed and paced up and
down the plane and then spoke to a
flight attendant and it's attempted to
get these three men removed so they
can't put on the base that they were
buzzed leveled on by stating that they
are disgusting and threats oh my god
piece of [ __ ] the funny thing is the
guys don't even like fit the description
of a Euro Bros like they only go to the
trans clubs I guess I thought ponytail
yeah yeah they look like they're about
to go to EDC or something like they're
just Western as hell dude no joke my
friend he's Egyptian and he got thrown
off a plane because of this like
actually they removed him because where
what does he look like he was a like 21
yeah and he's Egyptian and he like I
think his head was shaved at that time
and he's just in a hoodie I and like you
know is it a airport you know
comfortable there this happens all the
time yeah he looks um you know like he's
got Middle Eastern features because he's
Egyptian just based off his face yeah
yeah and and that he's wearing a hoodie
or whatever and he made I guess he's not
a computational person he's just a
really quiet person and like I guess
they made people too uncomfortable and
he got thrown off the plane and this was
like 2012 this happens all the time
some people is that happen to you
because your name is Omar so myself and
my friend we went to New York is your
friend of the cities names else he's
actually Christian but he's from Iraq
but it doesn't matter because I can't
distinguish that is uh we were going
I've been pulled over for secondary
inspection where I'm like hey what up
people not surprised but he his name's
Ellis and he said of me he's like man
they're not gonna pull me over I said
Ellis your passports from you know Iraq
you know I I think it's gonna happen and
so they asked he had just his uh he
bought alcohol for his father so he had
from duty-free and the person I went
ahead whatever cool and then she asked
like what's in the bag and he said
alcohol for my father and she said yeah
you gotta go that way
but my story there's actually a Canadian
social media guy just rain you guys know
Jeff Wainwright where he had a story
he's been on the show yeah he's a Sikh
so he's not Muslim but yeah but he
yeah they're doing the inspections can't
distinguish that and he was told even
though it's a religious custom for him
to wear his turban to remove it oh no
and so he was told and otherwise and
it's it's viewed as that's huge
sacrilegious to remove it follow that if
he had to unfortunately he had a walk
outside with his hair down and leave as
a result and so yeah there's a lot of
crazy stuff like that yeah they get I
think some stuff gets over poured in
some stuff gets unreported I think
actually I have a friend just another
story in Toronto that his name's Osama
and around the time of September 11th
where that stuff happened he was bullied
repeat like yeah and he actually became
a Sikh boxer then as a result of that no
joke he started taking lessons to [ __ ]
people oh yeah and he eventually became
really good at it so it happens it
definitely happens and some people would
want last thing I would say about this
topic they just have in the name Omar
where people yeah my friend's name was
OMA yeah like either you're Muslim not
that there's anything wrong with that
but then it you're like this Arab
terrorist this and that probably a year
on my YouTube i delete around 500
comments so they probably look at leave
people call you terrorists some some
sort of negative association with being
Muslim or terrorist or bombs or whatever
this that so it's like it's like any
other racial slur but something it's a
name now used all over so it originates
as a Muslim name just like a but like
Christian is a Christian name but you
could be with the name Christian from
all over but in Latino communities in
african-american communities it's a very
common name now but yeah so yeah that
happens right I think it's origin
originated from a Muslim name its Arabic
name oh yeah but then there's Spanish
influence the Moors influence the
Spanish so that's how the Mexicans have
a lot of Arabic names
yeah the south of Spain was a controlled
by the Moors up until whatever like the
14th century damn man that's so crazy
because I know that you know how they're
doing the whole like what's the word
like the immigration thing and blocking
out Muslims and things like Muslim ban
yeah there's a huge soso Japanese marry
that have been in terms like they're
they're coming out and they're fighting
for the rights of that because they're
like oh you know this seems strikingly
similar similar to what we went through
and I'm like damn that's I never really
saw the similarities because I think me
just being in my bubble it doesn't and I
only know like a handful of Muslims that
are very Americanized yeah so I never
really made the connection of like how
much [ __ ] you have to go through for
being of that culture and what's weird
too is if there's things that are viewed
as being acceptable obviously if these
days that probably fifty years from now
we would look back not quite the same as
internment camps but something similar
were we accepted but it's like well how
how did society let those things happen
so you know what's something that you
see would this idea were a joke brought
up the idea of a Muslim bein for
specific countries or even some of the
things were the discussions of the
immigration where me per se and you take
a look at the economics of it that
immigrants by and large let's say in
American Canada operates largely on a
meritocracy which means those that have
higher education if you have a
bachelor's if you have a master's you
have a PhD how many taxi drivers I know
in Canada that have PhD I'm like this
dude is a billion times smarter than me
but it's a meritocracy which means that
American Canada take a look at
immigrants with the most qualifications
normally and there's a small amount of
refugees which I believe you know we
should let in but then it's put on the
media that were freeloaders or this and
that there's actually statistics in
Toronto that showed that the average
immigrant commits far less crime like
it's basically the ideal citizen like
pays their taxes does they're better
than the trash that lives here yeah
that's my mom like my mom literally the
other day was saying like like that's so
[ __ ] up because she was like like me
I'm so grateful and she's like she
always votes every single like she looks
down on me because I like if I forget to
vote she's like how could you know like
she's so invested because she's like I'm
so grateful here because my situation
back home was horrible yeah so we got
grandparents they're like super
patriotic they're like very respectful
to fly my grandpa was Navy that's how
they got over here from the Philippines
and they've always been like America
first and stuff and
they can barely speak English so the key
is the more Americanized we become they
should send us out to find our way back
into the country because it's like every
generation they become more entitled and
they go they become more like yeah and
if you take a look at the economics
though which some people are ignorant to
that in a capitalist society you need a
positive surplus of the population
growth so you need more and more people
more the younger generation of work and
if it wasn't for immigrants both in
America and Canada then that would
severely affect the economics of the
countries which is why in JIT the
workforce is shrinking yeah so you look
in Japan our work and innovations in
Japan if you take a look in the 80s they
thought Japan if you look at also the
GDP and everything that they're gonna be
not only the next superpower but
rivaling the US but what the feet of
them was a lack of population growth it
became stagnant and then I regressed and
that's part of the major reasons behind
the recession so in ways if people talk
about oh look at the economy booming and
like that's because there's more people
there's more workers the native
population is not replacing that with
more children so that's why it's not
like it's not a handout like oh oh like
you're lucky to be here it's like now
this is they're fighting for their way
and that's the only reason why America
and Canada is not like Japan because the
if you think about the local population
or the generation that's been here there
is a dilution or the white population is
shrinking because of that factor right
more of them are becoming educated they
want to stay in their careers longer
they're only having one kid or whatever
immigrant populations are coming in and
they're killing it yeah and they're
doing amazing but they're also
innovating and doing all this awesome
stuff that's keeping it going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]